- Okay, so just let me go
back to the main point here,
which is to really thank
Ali for the amount of work
that she has put into this conference.
I'm really thrilled to be here
and I am really excited about a day
in which I'm sure I'm gonna learn a lot
because as you will discover very quickly,
my knowledge of the world ends
around the Industrial Revolution.
So it is really thrilling to be here.
So just to give you a
little bit of context here,
I am going to plunge this conversation
about assemblies and lotteries
into a sort of a broader
historical context here,
looking at what I will, sort
of like a defining moment,
as instances of historical
collective governance.
And so here I don't really have,
let me just begin with a
shout-out to my collaborators
without whom this project
would never have existed,
including Nathan Schneider at
the University of Colorado,
and one of our postgraduate
RAs, Riley Wong,
who's done a bunch of the analysis
that I will present today,
and a bunch of RAs at Kings where I work.
In this context, in this room,
I don't have to articulate so much
the sort of like motivating
question behind the project,
which is, of course,
something along the lines
of what Allie has already articulated.
It's not so much per se, the sort of like,
a collapse of of liberal democracy,
although that is certainly
behind the scenes,
it is also just the sheer surge in demand
in spaces for participation.
Something that I, as a historian,
particularly historian
across of classical Athens,
have sort of like a grown up studying,
but it is certainly not something that
at least until like 10
years ago, so to speak,
really permeated the work of politics.
And we could, Allie has
already shown some evidence
of the sort of like a, the
steepness of this surge,
but also the variety of
instances in which we see sort
of like forms of participation,
sort of like a popup in modern
politics online and offline.
Things like political
parties registering citizen
permanent institutions like
redistricting commissions,
and of course the climate
assemblies that have taken up
so much of the sort of a newspaper,
front pages in recent years.
So the sort of like a motivating question
for a historian like me or someone trained
in history like me is that we sort
of like fret a lot about
these modern experiments
with participatory governance.
But of course participatory
governance is not a
21st century phenomenon.
It is something that is
suddenly aided by technology,
but that did not begin in 1990 or 1970.
And so the problem though, is
that once you start looking
into collective governance
in an historical perspective,
what you get is a pretty sort
of like a strange story.
And the story begins with the
sort of like a suitability
for humans to live in small
bands of hunter/gatherers,
where horizontal governance was
easy of course for a variety
of reasons, heterogeneous,
homogeneous preferences,
small scale and so on and so forth.
And then we see sort of like a
large-scale collective
governance experiments pop up
throughout history, but in a
particular part of the world.
So this is of course classical Athens
and Republican Rome, the sort of the
17th century and onward
experiences of early modern Europe.
But of course collective
governance in historical
perspective is not a European phenomenon,
as this story, this very
influential story seems to suggest.
We have plenty of evidence of
collective governance outside
of Europe from various
disciplines, archeology,
anthropology, some political science.
But it is, this evidence,
is really not systematized.
And as so, the result I
believe, is that we don't
really have a clear view
of other world conditions,
collective governance arises, survives
or sort of like it flourishes and when
and in other world conditions it fails.
So the project that I'm
gonna be describing a
little bit today, before I delve more
specifically into the question
of historical assemblies
and the use of the lot is a project
that looks at instances
of collective governance
throughout history and across the world,
which is arguably a
slightly over-ambitious way
of stating what this project is all about.
And I can talk a little
bit about the limit
and the boundaries of this in the Q&A,
if people are interested, but the reasons
why we're doing this are twofold.
First, again, if we sort of
like believe the standard story
of collective governance
and the European evidence
that we have for it, I think it is fair
to say the theories that we build on,
on this evidence are limited, are partial.
And so what we want to
do with this evidence
that I will describe
in a moment is to sort
of like broaden our theories
of collective governance.
But the theory and the source
of science is not the whole story.
With a bunch of collaborators also trying
to turn this data set
into a tool that people,
the communities online and offline,
can actually use to build more resilient,
self-governing practices today.
And of course part of the
sort of like me being here,
I guess today, is that this data set
among other things can be
used to take a look at,
for example, particular
mechanisms such as the lotteries.
So I'm gonna be doing that today.
But before we get there,
I wanna spend a little bit
of time describing the database,
without which I think it'd
be hard to get the context,
and give you some preliminary
findings from the two years
of data collection that
we have conducted so far.
I'll spend a little bit of time describing
what we know about the use
of the lot, which is indeed,
spoiler alert, not so much.
And then I'm gonna try to
give you a bit of context on
how historical assemblies
actually got things done,
including but also beside
the use of the lot.
And then Allie sort of
like provoked me a bit
for this last bit to give you
a sense of like how I use,
or how I imagine this evidence,
this historical evidence
might be used in the process
of actually thinking about
institution building today.
So after a lot of talking
about history, we're gonna get
to the meat at the very end,
so please stay awake for that.
It's gonna be great.
Okay, so I'm gonna be describing
for a few minutes what
the database looks like.
And this is sort of gonna
include some definitions.
So two years of data collection,
we've got 66 communities,
not a lot guys, but
this is what we've got.
The communities that enter
the data set are communities
that meet at least one criterion
or necessarily one criterion,
that they have one collective
governance institution
that is an institution
within which a group
of more than one person makes decisions
on behalf of a community.
The crucial criterion for
what defines a collective
governance institution,
is drawn by, from the
work of David Stasavage.
This is for the sort of
the dorks in the room,
that are like really into the
social science behind this.
If you don't know who David
Stasavage is, it doesn't matter.
The idea here is what, I
suppose that many of you
who are scholars will,
but the bottom line is,
the idea is that participants in these
collective governance institutions
need to be independent
of a higher authority if it exists.
And so this is the basic
criterion discriminating
between early democracy and
early autocracy in David's work,
for those of you who know
what I'm talking about.
So 66 communities within.
Yes, please.
- [Audience Member] Quick
clarifying question.
What does the high authority here?
What are we looking at the principle or?
- Yeah, this would be a
higher authority understood,
like a king or an emperor or even like,
a higher governor, right?
And so the idea here is that
if the line of command is one
of dependency, you are essentially
like, implementing rules
that come up from a higher authority
that doesn't really meet
the basic requirement.
- [Audience Member] So voters would not be
an example of higher authority?
- No, no, no, that would not be the case.
So within each community there
are a number of institutions,
some of which are institutions
for collective governance,
some are not, and so we're
looking actually at the nesting
of collective governance practices
within larger structures.
And each institution has
what we call mechanisms.
And the mechanisms are
really the nitty gritty
of how people got things
done within the institutions,
the actual rules, lotteries, elections,
the various types of sort of like tools
that we then further
classified or categorized
in mechanisms that define
access to the institutions,
mechanisms that define
decision-making practices
and mechanism that regulate
enforcement practices.
Okay, so this is just to
give you an overview of
what we've got in the dataset.
We have got coverage of
all regions of the world,
except that of course the evidence
from Europe is preponderant.
I doubt that this is ever gonna go away,
but this is definitely a
product of what the evidence,
what kind of evidence
is easily accessible.
But essentially by a bunch of undergrads
at King's College, London,
which is a bunch of evidence
from Europe,
We are now changing
dramatically the way in which
we conduct the data collection,
which is gonna bring us in contact
with communities in
various parts of the world,
that are not Western
Europe and North America.
And I can talk a little
bit about that second stage
in the Q&A if anyone is interested.
But for the time being,
what matters here is that
what we're trying to do
here is actually again,
shift the focus of attention beyond Europe
and to try to understand
what collective governance looks like
in other places of the world.
When we look at the communities by size,
we see this again, like,
relatively broad coverage,
but a significant cluster around 10,
the sort of like the size
that includes memberships
between 10,000 and a hundred
thousand participants.
So not large, but also not
tiny in historical perspective.
And when we look at the
time we see a clustering
of communities in the first millennium BC
and in the second millennium AD.
This again, I doubt is an
actual empirical result
of the analysis and it's
mostly driven by the kind
of evidence that we have at our disposal
that covers the sort of
like a usual suspects
from the largely sort
of European tradition.
So we will see if by looking
at other non-European cases,
the timeline shifts with the evidence.
I just wanted to give you a sense of like,
what these mechanisms look like.
So of course this matters to you
because it includes the
lotteries as a mechanism,
I will talk about this
in a moment, of access
as a fundamental, one of the
primary perhaps mechanism
for accessing in collective
governance institutions.
But as you can see, there are
a number of other mechanisms
that come up in this, in this data set
that suggest variation
across selection mechanisms.
We see, when we look at
decision-making mechanisms,
again, a preponderance of usual suspects,
such as councils and assemblies.
But we also see sort of
like the growing importance
of things like deliberation,
consensus and representation.
And we look at enforcement
again, we see courts
and tribunals as the primary bodies
for enforcement procedures, but also
some interesting evidence
on the use of scrutinies
and practices like ostracism
and judicial review.
So this is just to give you a sense
of what is in this data set.
So as I said, we have spent a couple
of years collecting evidence.
Again, a bunch of this
evidence is from Europe.
We're trying to push that sort
of like, push against that.
But we are not quite there yet.
We have spent a good chunk of our summer,
this past summer looking at exactly
what this database is telling us
about collective governance.
And so I'm just gonna be
mentioning three results,
which I think are perhaps
like promising enough
that I still think that this
work should be continued,
I should continue to do this.
But maybe this is something
that you can advise me
on towards the end of this presentation,
if you think that there's no there there.
So the primary finding
that seems of relevance is
that the mechanisms that
we see operating within
collective governance
communities that are in Europe
are not the same as the
mechanisms that we see
otherwise in other places over the world.
So that is quite interesting.
This is just to give you a sense of
what this looks like in the correlations,
that is a cluster of
mechanisms that we associate
with collective governance
today in the United States.
We tend to think about collective
governance as something
that has assemblies, as
we've heard today, councils,
and things like lotteries,
term limits, rotation.
These mechanisms are very
familiar to the Western tradition
of collective governance.
But it turns out that when
we look outside of Europe,
these mechanisms cease to
be present just simply.
And when we see correlations
between collective
governance outside of Europe
and particular mechanisms,
we see something else
popping up, essentially.
These include informal sanctions,
consultation procedures,
popularity meritocracy
and local councils and blood
relations and meritocracy.
And again, like, there is not
just variation between Europe
and other parts of the world, but also
within non-European
sort of like locations,
we see variation as well.
And so this is really for us,
a sort of like a indication
that we should perhaps, continue
with the data collection
in these other places
and try to figure out
what kind of picture we get
of collective governance
when we take a more
global perspective on it.
A couple of more, perhaps less,
sort of like a interesting
and a little bit boring findings,
but please bear with me.
There seems to be an
inverted-U shaped relationship
between size and duration.
This is quite interesting because it seems
to push against the idea
that collective governance
collapses at scale.
It seems what we find
in the dataset so far is
that there is a sort of like a sweet spot,
where collective governance
communities seem to last longer.
Again, lasting longer is not
necessarily a sign of success,
this is problematic, but this
is what the data says so far.
And so we sort of like,
this seems to be like
some sort of like illustrative evidence
that suggests that there is
something more interesting
about scale and collective governance than
what we tend to imagine,
which is essentially
that as scale increases the probability
of collective governance decreases.
The third finding that
I want to talk about is,
again, variation by size.
So this is a similar perhaps, result,
and it again suggests that
there is something going on
at the level of different communities
of different sizes seem to be operating
through different mechanisms.
So again, this is perhaps
something to keep in mind
as we think about building
collective governance spaces.
It seems from the evidence that we've got
that different mechanisms like,
a mechanism might not apply equally
to communities of various sizes.
And here when we look
at sort of mechanisms
with European cases, we see
this clustering of a series
of mechanisms at a particular,
sort of this middle range sizes.
When we take Europe out, we see
more variation across sizes.
And again, this is in
part, the problem here is
that we don't have a lot of evidence,
as I mentioned about non-European cases.
We certainly don't have
as robust evidence about
non-European cases, but these
results are sort of like,
illustrative of something that is going on
in sort of like different
parts of the world.
They might tell us something new
about collective governance.
Let me just stop for a second
before I get into the more
meaty part to make sure
that A, you have not fallen asleep,
B, you are still with
me and I have not jumped
over massive logical steps.
Good, excellent.
Okay, so because this
conference is about the lot
and assemblies, Allie
asked me to please sort
of like a reveal some
information about what this
dataset says about this
particular part topic.
And it turns out that
again, I'm very happy
to be contradicted here by other people
that are looking at
lotteries more specifically,
but what emerges in this particular case
of collective governance communities
or communities operating
or building collective
governance spaces is
that the lot is not very common.
And so I'm gonna try to
sort of like articulate why
that might be the case and
where the lot is common,
how it was used, and this is
gonna echo some of the comments
that Allie has already made.
And then I'm gonna try to articulate
what else is going on in
historical assemblies,
in terms of these access
and selection mechanisms
that seems to be more prominent.
So again, when we talk about lotteries,
it is in historical practice,
it is worth distinguishing
between various uses of the lot.
So we might think about
the lot as a system
to allocate resources.
Allie has a excellent paper on
land lotteries, for example.
This is now what I'm looking at.
The lotteries that I'm looking
at here are uniquely systems
for access to institutions.
So they're a system of
selection of members
of an institution.
And from the evidence that
we have collected so far,
the lot is really not that common,
and it only applies to three cases.
The third of which is I
believe a coding mistake
by one of my RAs, and it's the only one
that is not in Europe.
And so I sort of like,
the database is not a
representative sample
or what is the word I'm looking for,
like comprehensive view of
historical collective governance.
But the evidence that we
have so far really suggests
that the lot is infrequent
and fundamentally European.
Within Europe, it was used in
a variety of different ways.
So this again echoes something
that Allie has already said.
It is used within the political process
in very different ways and
even within each community,
it can be used in different ways.
So I'm giving you the
two examples of that.
The first comes from Venice, Costas.
(speaking off-mic)
- [Audience Member] Curiosity question,
Would you, would you say,
or would it be a plausible
assumption to say
that you see this lotteries in Venice or
in Greek polis just because
you can as assure hard degree
of preference homogeneity there.
So then they would be more
easy with accepting a lottery
as opposed to other more
heterogeneous contexts.
- Great, that is possible, I don't know.
I don't think that the dataset
at this stage can allow me
to reach conclusions,
partly because again,
this is a very small sample.
It is, the N is equal to one, to two.
- [Audience Member] Anecdotally or like,
descriptively or like-
- Yeah, yeah, and again, like,
I can talk about Ancient Athens
and your eyes pop out, which
I'm not gonna do today.
But it is certainly true
that I think in the case
of Athens in particular,
compared to like the,
I don't wanna be ahistorical here
because consider Athens is a complicated
part of part of the world.
Because if you think
about Athens in terms of
what we expect today representation
or inclusion to be, of
course Athens was elitist.
This is something that
Allie mentioned earlier.
Except that the comparison
to Athens was Persia,
where no one was
participating to begin with.
So again, it depends really
on where you're standing.
And so preference homogeneity
in Athens is something
that really is in the
eyes of the beholder.
So it changes depending on who you ask.
If you ask sort of like
a modern commentator,
of course, the Athenians
were extremely homogeneous
in terms of preferences.
If you're thinking however,
in the historical context,
particularly given
heterogeneity in terms of like,
associational life, occupation,
socioeconomic status,
political views, I think about Plato,
that to me is evidence of
preference of heterogeneity.
So again, I think this
is a great question,
but not something that I'm
sure this data set could
thoroughly address.
Kevin, do you have a burning?
- [Kevin] Sure, yeah, so just
on the preference homogeneity point,
one thing, maybe you could,
if you look at places
of similar size, right?
- Yeah.
- [Kevin] That might give
you some kind of very rough
indication of it, but you could also look
at the contemporary justifications
of the institution, right?
So is it that we have lottery
because we all think we are equally,
we all have roughly the same views,
and so it really doesn't matter
who occupies the office in Athens.
That doesn't seem to be the case.
It's more about equality,
we are all sort of,
we respect everyone equally.
Everyone who would like to have a place
and speak and so forth is, yeah.
(audience member speaking off mic)
- [Audience Member] Because
if everybody has the same.
So you are right-
- [Audience Member] Risk aversion might
non-monotonically value because if I know
everybody has the same preference,
I'm willing to take the risk, lottery.
If I know everybody has
very diverse preference,
better to the lottery.
It's only in the mid-point
that I would be willing
to switch from a lottery to something
that I could potentially control more.
Or I could like, in a situation where,
I mean I'm 86, 70% more
strong, and I can just think
I have full control of the of the power.
Today or do homogenous then
the risk aversion relationship
that might not be monotonic.
I mean that's a hypothesis, right?
- Are you settled with your own questions?
Okay, let me just continue.
So again, like I don't think,
looking at justification
for the lot is going to
be rife with problems
of what is the evidentiary basis
that's justifying that use?
And looking at size might be interesting,
but again, like the end is so small
that it's gonna be essentially
like noninformative.
But this is again, like if
data collection processes
in the future will change
this picture, I think
that those questions will
become more relevant.
So again, just going back
to these two examples,
which I think are pretty
illustrative of the range of use
of the lot in historical societies,
although of course these
are perhaps some of the most
well known cases in just
to give you a brief,
sort of like a comparison
between a situation
in which the lot was really folded
into extremely complex procedure,
but at a very high stakes
in the political process.
So the Doge is the highest
author authority in Venice
between the 11th and the 14th century.
And the selection of
the Doge was entrusted
as Greif and Laitin summarized
in this passage here,
to a committee, which was itself,
selected by a combination
of lot and delegation.
And the process was famously
extraordinarily complicated,
involving nine steps.
And so again, we see the lot,
and this is perhaps a
point that is relevant also
for some of the questions
in the round table later.
The lot here is not just a
sort of like a unique system
of selection that is
presented as better or worse
or for particular reasons,
depending on the particular sort
of needs of the society,
but it is really part
of a much more complex system
of selection that is aimed
at a variety of outcomes,
including some of the outcomes
that Allie has discussed.
Particularly the sort of like attempt
at eliminating elite
capture by, in this case,
clans and social groups
within the polity of Venice.
In Athens, the lot was
used much more broadly.
In fact, the three of the
four main institutions
included the use of the
lot one way or another.
The third, the fourth being the assembly,
that was where members were selected on
a first come, first serve basis.
But in looking at the other
three main institutions
in the polity of Athens,
we see that again,
like, the lot was used
abundantly and differentially.
In the council that I will
talk about more in a second,
it was used for the selection
of a representative sample
of jurors in the courts.
It was very interestingly,
again for dorks in the room,
well known to be used on a
daily basis for the selection
of jury panels in the law courts
through the system known as Kleroterion.
This is the part where
I sort of like flash you
this like ancient system of randomization
that the Athenians used.
And in the council again, it was used in a
slightly different way that
I will talk about in greater
depth in a moment, sorry.
And with the magistrates, it was also used
for the selection of some
magistrates but not all.
So again, within each
institutions we see a number
of potentially different
selection processes
and variation across them as well.
So this is the part where
the slides were sort
of like messed up.
So I wanted to just suggest, let's see.
Okay, so the point here
is that the lot is not
very commonly used based
on my data collection
among historical cases
of historical communities practicing form
of collective governance.
So what else is used, let's
say in historical assemblies?
And this again, just to give
you a sense of what I mean
by historical assemblies,
we coded a variety of them.
Assemblies that operate
at the central level,
which means the higher
administrative level
within a community, and
assemblies that operate
at the local level.
So sort of like subunits
within a community.
And we coded both at the local,
at the central level, assemblies
that featured some sort
of like, elite membership,
or just a broader citizen assembly
of the kinds that we are discussing today.
Assemblies, again, this
reflects some of the stuff
that I've already discussed,
are by and large a European
and a little bit Asian
as well, phenomenon.
And they are overwhelmingly
in the dataset central-
and citizen-based, not elite.
Okay, so just to give you a
sense of what else is going on,
the lot appears so high up in this matrix,
largely because it is used
so frequently in Athens
and in other Greek polis.
So this is actually a
somewhat of a false result
because what's driving
the frequency here is
really the sort of multiple uses
that particularly Greek
polis made of lotteries.
What else is going on in
terms of access mechanisms
in global historical
collective governance,
are the use of elections,
the use of age boundaries
and the use of blood relations
and property requirements.
So if we look at global history,
elections certainly
play a fundamental role.
But the other systems of
selecting into into assemblies,
again by and large central
nonelite assemblies,
are systems that we actually associate
with more oligarchical,
perhaps, structures today.
Okay, alright, everyone's still with me?
All right, you're still
nodding, which is amazing.
I really appreciate it.
Okay, how am I on time, Allie?
- [Allie] You're good,
you have 17 more minutes.
- 17?
- [Allie] 17, that includes-
- Oh, okay, so I have two, okay.
So I'm gonna actually
go quickly through this.
And this is something that I spend a lot
of time on, which is like, okay,
let's say that I do these things because
I'm a classical historian by training,
which is only part of
the reason, arguably.
And I study historical collective
governance because again,
this is what someone
trained as a historian does.
I actually think that
there's a little bit more
to it than that, and I
think that this evidence is
actually fundamental to understand how
to build institutions today, particularly
at a time when sort of like
Western liberalism seems
to be at the point of like descendance
as opposed to like ascendance.
But the question of like how
to actually use this evidence
to build institutions today
is to me, not that obvious.
And so some of us have
been spending a little bit
of time trying to write about
it and try to think about it.
My colleague Nathan Schneider,
and David Stasavage at NYU,
whom I mentioned earlier,
wrote this like very nice
short piece in NOEMA,
where they suggest how
lessons from early democracies
or historical collective
governance communities can be used
to think about platform regulation.
And a couple of years ago I
wrote a sort of provocative,
perhaps, piece in "Wired"
that was sort of like meant
to use the example of the Athenian council
to think about algorithmic accountability.
So I tend to never mention
that piece to anyone,
but Allie knows about it and
she asked me to talk about it.
So that's, it's her fault essentially.
- [Allie] What did you say in the piece?
- Oh look, let me tell you all about it.
So this again, the sort of
like the provocation came
from my involvement in an Open AI report
that came out in 2020, which for questions
about algorithm accountability,
this is equivalent to ancient history.
The report was on trustworthy AI
and the report essentially sort of like,
summarized the question of
like how to build institutions
for algorithm accountability,
that actually included some
sort of like accountability
to the companies, with the words like,
we should create external auditing bodies.
But of course the report
never sort of like mentioned
what those auditing
bodies ought to look like.
And so the piece was meant
to sort of like provoke
people into thinking
about how to use historical evidence
for thinking about this
kind of institution building
in ungoverned spaces, perhaps,
still ungoverned, certainly in the U.S.
So again, the premises of
the piece were the sort
of like, just provoke
readers into thinking
about the fundamental
clash between the use
of algorithms in society and thinking
about democracies and assemblies.
In one case you get sort
of an optimization function
that tells you this is
the best possible outcome,
but of course this is not something
that will surprise many
of you in the room.
This is not how politics works.
And in fact, based on what
might we might describe
as the original lesson
of democracy, these types
of societal trade-offs are
best addressed by listening
to varied voices, by many voices.
And so the piece was sort of like, again,
trying to look at empirical evidence
of how large-scale citizen governance
on tough questions might occur.
And so the provocation was
to model a idealized institution
for algorithmic accountability on the
Athenian council of 500.
And here the devil's
in the details, right?
I don't wanna sort of like
bore you too much with this,
but the idea here is that
the Boule featured very few,
very interesting rules
that in a sort of like,
nice little package ensured
broad citizen participation
and representation.
So let me address some of
the questions that Allie got
because the Athenians
seem to have sort of like,
a thought about
stratification in a slightly
different way, which is
essentially over time.
And so they used a lot to select people
across relevant cleavages,
can talk about that again,
until your eyes pop out.
But let me not bore you too much.
They had an annual mandate.
So you're in and then you're out.
Demand cannot be iterated.
It cannot be iterated consecutively
and in general, you
cannot iterate the mandate
for more than two years.
The result of this,
some classical historians
have done the numbers,
is that a huge chunk of the Athenian part
of the population that was eligible
for participation in
politics, a huge chunk of
that population actually,
at one point in their lives,
participated in this institution.
And that had some really interesting sort
of like a knock-on effect.
The knock-on effects are
that these rules enable
this particular institution
to avoid some of the pitfalls
that we normally associate
with collective governance,
such as the possibility of lead capture,
but also the idea that a
collective governance is
just a bunch of ignorant
people, in the Athenian case,
sitting on a hill making
decisions about things
that they don't know anything
and therefore that's
why they need experts.
And the Athenians seem to
have sort of like overcome
this problem through the system of rules
that promote knowledge
aggregation within the institution
at a given time and learning over time.
So again, I don't wanna
sort of like spend more
than I have really
spent, in terms of time,
sort of like trying to
convince you that there is
something valuable thinking about
these historical institutions
for institution building today.
But I hope to have given you a
sense that it is in fact sort
of like, perhaps about time,
to think about experiments
in collective governance
that are both past and global,
to think about systems
of collective governance
that go beyond this sort
of like a real interesting,
but also peculiar in my perspective,
sort of like a focus on the lot,
and also to think very,
very clearly in sort
of like a clear eyed-ly,
perhaps, about application
of this evidence to modern
institution building.
I'm gonna shut up. Thank
you for your consideration.
(audience applauding)
Some of you are still
awake, I think, Allie.
- [Allie] Hi, I'm Allie Cerone,
you've heard me talk a lot.
So one thing I think that's interesting
about this research is one scale.
So a lot of the people
in this room are trying
to figure out can we scale-
- Right.
- [Allie] Not just governance,
but different type of scale,
but to what extent, like, can
deliberative groups be bigger?
Can we have multiple of them running?
Can we start doing thousands
of people in assemblies?
So what does your research
teach us about scale?
And this kind of goes
back to Costa's question.
It's interesting because
we see historically,
a lot of the cool stuff with
lotteries happened in Europe-
- Right.
- [Allie] But these were
also the first democracies, they were also
easier to govern, they were richer.
There's a lot of like other correlates
that might kind explain this,
but it is the case that
even today, so in the U.S.,
we have a lot of people in this room
that are doing U.S.-based activities,
but Europe is by far
surpassing us in terms
of the experimentation, the novelty,
and like having this be routine.
So people know about citizens
assemblies in Europe,
the average American citizen
I would argue does not.
And so is there, is
there a European magic?
Is this just kind of path dependence,
is there something, do you think,
that the European way can be exported?
- Yeah, so about scale,
I think that this is,
in fact, one of the biggest
takeaway from this research is
to push against the idea
that there is something
about a small scale that
favors collective governance
and something about large
scale that makes it impossible.
And again, I think that the
devil's in the details here.
I'm not gonna say that
that fundamental assumption
about the sort of like what makes
collective governance
flourish is falsified
by what I'm seeing.
What I'm seeing is in fact
that collective governance
institutions occur at any scale
in a polity from very,
very small to pretty large.
And what seems to be
particularly relevant is the ways
in which they are nested
within other institutions.
And so I think that this
is in fact something
that the database can really give us
because we are not gonna have a congress
of lottery-elected participants.
And so I think that the
question for us is not so much
to think about substitution,
but to think about like, ways in which
we can integrate systems
of collective governance
within other hierarchical representative
and various types of institutions.
So scale to me is a red herring, per se.
The real question is
about like, articulation
of various types of
institutions, with potentially
very different mechanisms of selection,
of decision making,
and so on and so forth.
And again, I don't think that
we're gonna get much past
that even almost already ideal version
of doing politics.
I think that participation
has a role to play,
but not everywhere, perhaps.
And this is again,
like, the social science
that we need is really
about these questions.
So that's about scale.
On Europe, I think that Europe has,
that's interesting, I don't know.
But the answer to your
question is I don't know,
but I think that Europe
has a long-term tradition
of types and forms of
collective governance.
It also has of course,
for a variety of reasons,
political fragmentation is something
that political scientists love
to think about all the time.
A sort of like a more like, ease
with less hierarchical
forms of governance.
I don't think that the United
States is in a particularly
sort of like a different position.
And I think that there's
actually quite a bit
of experimentation in the U.S.
It's just the U.S. is so much bigger.
And I think that it's
also probably true that,
I wonder if that is correct,
like what are the expectations
of the average European citizen
versus the average American citizen?
I think that they change
also dramatically,
so I'm not quite sure that it is true
that the average European
citizen knows about citizen
assemblies in the way
that, but I don't know.
This is like, my complete speculation.
I think that there is something historical
that favored the historical creation
of collective governance in Europe,
but again, I think that
there is a lot of evidence
that suggests that
collective governance is not
just European phenomenon.
We're just not looking at it.
And so again, the project
here goes into the
quite thorny question of
how to elicit that evidence,
which is usually couched in or accessible
through much more
hard-to-access processes,
sometimes involving oral
histories and interviews
and so on and so forth.
And that's where we're going,
but that's gonna be a can
of worms, so to speak.
Yes, Chris, I guess you're next.
- [Chris] Hi, my name
is Chris, I'm with Meta.
And really appreciated hearing
more about your studies
and also really enjoyed
your "Wired" article.
- Thanks, Chris.
- [Chris] I'm really
excited to talk more about
that as well. I would
just note that at Meta,
we are head of Open AI in
deliberative discourse.
Just just a friendly plug.
But I guess as you talk about scaling,
I think to follow up on
the question on scaling,
something that we're super interested in.
I am curious, as you looked at data
on deliberative discourse or
mechanisms outside of Europe,
you highlighted like,
some various kind of ways
that people structured their deliberation,
understanding that
there's a dearth of data,
or just less data or less examples.
I guess I'm just wondering, do you think,
is it from a scaling
perspective, does there need
to be a difference in selection
or do you also think in
terms of the structure
of the deliberation, again,
understanding that there's not
as much data, but like
is there as scaling moves
towards more inclusion in the
global south in particular,
does there need to be an adjustment
in the actual model of deliberation?
- Yeah, so this is, I think,
where this result is most interesting.
This is it.
So the idea that there
are different mechanisms,
so in a best case scenario,
what this on the Y axis,
you would have mechanisms here.
And so what you're seeing here is in fact,
the mechanisms that operate in
differently sized communities.
The data here is too terrible
to draw any conclusion, really.
And it'll be like sort of
like a little bit absurd
for me to tell you things that I actually,
I can't really say.
But what this result tells us is
that it is precisely this kind
of question that we should ask.
This is clearly indicating
that for the communities
that we have in the dataset,
different mechanisms of access
of decision making, I'll get
to deliberation in a second,
but selection, decision-making enforcement
of decisions, vary across size groups.
And so that might be, that will be one
of the things that we try
to investigate further.
Just to be clear, we
don't really, we have,
deliberation is one of the
decision-making mechanisms,
but it is not, by far, the only one.
So it is one of about
a hundred mechanisms.
- [Chris] Thanks, I wonder,
so one of the things
about having clustering of
decision-making processes
or collective governance institutions,
is it raises questions
about diffusion, right?
So it's not-
- Yeah.
- [Chris] Just Athens, right?
It's a whole bunch of Greek
polises, polis, whatever.
And so I wonder to what extent
the dataset as it exists now
or as as you plan to
make it, would tell us
about diffusion networks?
What can we infer about this stuff?
So it's very interesting
how we have a, whatever,
a thousand years without lots in Europe
and then it pops up in Venice.
And I'm sure, given the way
that these types of things work,
people are talking about and thinking
about Greece and Venice.
- Yeah.
- [Chris] And likewise
today, when people talk
about in rooms like this, when
people talk about lotteries,
they point back to Athens.
So I wonder what what you have to-
- Yeah, no, this is a
great question and we are,
the next thing that we're gonna be doing,
is a clustering analysis
that's gonna tell us,
in fact if we have neighboring effects
or clustering effects of this kind,
particularly at the level
of the region or not.
Because that analysis
should tell us if we do have
this type of like, a
diffusion of institutions
within a sort of like a geographic region
or sub-region like we see
in Greece, for example.
That is a very striking,
in fact it is so striking
that as a classical historian
and so knowing pretty much
what I'm doing in that particular context,
I had to take the Greek
polis, and essentially squeeze
them into two entries in the dataset.
I've got Athens for which
we have enormous amount
of evidence, then I've
got Greek democracies,
then I've got Greek oligarchies.
And if I were to code all of them,
I would have 3,000 cases in Europe
and nothing for any of the other regions.
So those neighboring effects
and clustering effects
at the level of the
region are already evident
in this grouping, which by the way,
we're gonna have to sort
of like disaggregate
in some way.
But what we're trying to do
now is actually trying to sort
of like be agnostic about the existence
of those clusters and
run a clustering analysis
and see whether in fact
it is regional diffusion
or something else entirely
that is driving similarity
across communities.
Thank you, that's great.
- [Allie] And with that,
we're actually out of time.
Okay, great, thank you.
(audience applauding)